Narrator: In a lot of the
behind-the-scenes shots
from "Avatar: The Way of Water,"
you'll see these monitors.
Zoom in and you'll see the performance
of the actor playing
Quaritch, a 9-foot-tall Na'vi.
The robotic monitor was a reference
for the actor in the scene
and for the VFX team who
added the CG giant in post.
It was a huge step forward
from the first "Avatar,"
which only had a handful of scenes
with humans and Na'vi interacting
compared to the sequel.
Filmmakers have been making actors
taller or smaller than they really are
for over a century.
But making sure the scale is realistic
without ruining the illusion
is where the real work begins.
And one of the pioneers
in the space is Wētā,
the visual effects company
that's overseen some of
the most groundbreaking
CG characters of all sizes,
in movies like "The Lord of the Rings"
and "The Way of Water."
Eric: We always have to play games in film
to make that feel
and actually be able to
get good performances
from the different scale that you want.
If they're 6-foot, the
tree's going to need to be
30% smaller if the characters
are going to be 30% bigger.
So there's a lot of
planning involved there.
Narrator: It's a puzzle filmmakers
have been trying to solve
since the invention of film.
Take this shot of 1909's
"Princess Nicotine."
The tiny fairy next to
this normal-sized human
was actually standing on a
platform far behind the table.
This is known as forced perspective,
in which one performer in frame
will place themselves closer to the camera
and the other farther away.
Forced perspective requires
a sharp depth of field
so both the foreground and background
appear equally in focus.
And that means a lot of light.
Visual effects artist Peter Ellenshaw
said that when working on 1959's
"Darby O'Gill and the Little People,"
the production used so many lights
for the forced-perspective shots
that it blew out the circuit breakers
at a nearby power station.
Forced perspective works
when the characters are separated.
When they have to interact,
things get more complicated.
This was an issue Peter
Jackson encountered
when he started shooting
"The Lord of the Rings:
The Fellowship of the Ring"
with wizards, dwarves, and hobbits.
To expand how scale could
be used in these movies,
the crew had to manipulate
their sets and props
while filming at just the right angle.
Here you can see Gandalf and Frodo
sitting side by side.
All right, then, keep your secrets.
Narrator: But on set,
Elijah Wood was sitting
on a shorter stool pushed farther back,
while Ian McKellen sat right
in front of the camera.
These sorts of raised sets
are a common forced-perspective technique
that you can also see
two years later in "Elf."
And forced perspective
also needs to be paired
with props that are made to scale.
In this shot, Frodo and
Gandalf were actually
sitting at a table that
had been split apart.
On one side were
normal-sized props for Frodo.
And for Gandalf, a small-scale table
with a mug that was two-thirds the size.
The reason these
forced-prospective shots work
is that the camera stays still.
Most of the camera moves
were quite locked off.
Narrator: Once the camera
moves, the illusion is ruined.
Eric: It screwed with
your head a little bit
when you were on set,
because when you watched it from the side,
it didn't look right at all.
Narrator: To accomplish this
moving forced-perspective shot,
the crew placed the table
on a moving platform
and programmed the camera
to move in the opposite direction.
They programmed the
camera's moves in advance,
making them easy to replicate.
That way, in scenes like this one,
they could shoot the actors separately
in the exact same way
and seamlessly combine them.
The shorter Bilbo could walk in front of
the much taller Gandalf,
and it could all be combined
with the two versions of Bilbo's house:
one hobbit-sized
and one made 33% smaller for Gandalf.
Oh!
Narrator: And these shots could consist
of more than two characters at once.
Nine companions.
Narrator: To get all
four hobbits, two humans,
a dwarf, an elf, and a
wizard into the same shot,
the crew filmed scale
composites of each actor
against a blue screen
with the proper framing and camera angle
for the characters' heights.
The images were then composited together.
This technology continued
to be perfected and used
to expand the "Lord of
the Rings" universe.
But it hit a snag as
Wētā worked on "Avatar"
and "The Hobbit: An Unexpected Journey,"
two movies shot in 3D.
Eric: A lot of the cheats
we were able to get away with before,
we can't get away with as much now.
So instead of shooting with one camera,
you're shooting with side-by-side cameras,
so you get proper 3D.
The false perspective really
falls apart quite quickly,
because you understand
the depth of the shots.
The motion control really kicked into gear
for the "Hobbit" trilogy.
Narrator: At this point, the
cameras were much more precise
and reliable than they were
in the original trilogy.
Like during this sequence.
Eric: It got the results you needed.
You were able to do
camera moves you wanted,
you were able to move around,
do the different things you
had to do to get the shots.
Narrator: But it can pose a challenge
when the actors are
playing non-CG characters.
Because the actors were
frequently shot in different takes
to account for the differing heights,
they weren't able to directly
interact with one another.
It wasn't very actor-friendly.
Narrator: Size manipulation
is a lot easier
if the character is fully CG,
like the giant in "The BFG,"
played by Mark Rylance.
Mark could be on set
with actor Ruby Barnhill,
as long as he acted above
her on this platform.
But even this movie innovated
new riffs on past techniques.
For example, Ruby was
surrounded by oversized props
when her character was
in the giant's house.
But unlike past large-scale props,
some of them were blue.
That way, the animators
could add movements
to this giant-sized squash.
Some other tricks to
maintain proper eyeline
and sense of scale are
low tech but effective.
In the "Avengers" films,
Josh Brolin plays the 8-foot-tall Thanos.
The mo-cap sensors he wore were so good
at picking up subtle
expressions and movements
that his real height didn't matter
until he was interacting
directly with other characters.
So to fill out the
height gap in this shot,
Josh wore a cutout on top of his head
so Robert Downey Jr. knew
exactly where to look.
You can also see the 5'4" Tatiana Maslany
wearing a cutout here
to look like she's the 6'7" She-Hulk.
Just like in "The BFG,"
she stood on an elevated
platform in these shots
and occasionally sat on a cushion.
But eyeline isn't the only
issue you need to resolve
when making a performer taller.
In this walking shot,
She-Hulk isn't standing next to anybody,
but Wētā found another issue.
Tatiana's real stride didn't match up
with She-Hulk's much longer legs.
Where Tatiana would take 10 steps,
She-Hulk would take seven.
That's where retargeting, or
character mapping, comes in.
This is when the VFX artists
take all the movements and expressions
from the performance-capture cameras
and apply them to the animated character.
When the character is a different size,
Wētā's software Nuance
needs to fill in the gaps,
like in translating actor
Sam Worthington's posture
over his Na'vi body in "Avatar"
or turning Andy Serkis into Caesar
in the "Planet of the Apes" trilogy.
If he's quadrupedal, you want to make sure
that what is absolute here
from his performance is his two feet
and the markers on the
end of the arm extension.
Narrator: The crew worked
with actor Malia Arrayah
to retarget She-Hulk's stride.
Malia could serve as a more
height-appropriate stand-in.
But this isn't a new practice.
In the past, stand-ins were used in shots
where you couldn't see their face.
By having Malia's movements
recorded on a mo-cap stage,
VFX artists could map her stride,
along with Tatiana's facial capture,
onto She-Hulk.
Everything about you is just working.
Thank you!
Narrator: The better CG
and camera tech has gotten,
the more seamless these
scale shots can be.
For all of the technological breakthroughs
in the original "Avatar,"
there are actually very few shots
of humans and Na'vi characters together,
as the process at the time
was much less precise.
Take it easy. Don't get ahead of yourself.
Narrator: For instance,
the shot of Neytiri
holding Jake Sully's human body
was achieved by two green-suit performers
approximating Na'vi size.
But that new eyeline system
meant there could be many more shots
of humans and Na'vi together.
It consisted of a monitor
playing an actor's
previously recorded performance.
That monitor was attached
to overhead cables at four points.
So whenever Scoresby had
a scene with Quaritch,
the monitor would play back
Stephen Lang's performance
at the proper height.
It got rotations, it got height,
so as he moved around, it knew exactly
where his head was supposed to be,
his eyes were supposed to be,
and it moved around set.
Narrator: Take this shot,
where Quaritch walks alongside
two human-sized characters.
We had a live-action
character, Kevin Dorman,
actually walking beside them.
Kevin Dorman is the easy one, right?
He's just live-action character
walking on a construction set.
But he has to match the speed of Slang,
which was performance capture.
So we take the performance capture,
and we put it on the cable
cam, the eyeline system,
and we actually ran that
down the construction set,
and Kevin Dorman was able
to walk along with him,
and he had an eyeline,
so he knew the speed he
was supposed to walk.
Narrator: But it wasn't just the actors
who needed precise references.
Real-time depth compositing
allowed James Cameron to
see the CG performances
as the footage was being captured.
By seeing a rough version
of what the finalized
CG shot would look like,
the director could better set up shots
of CG and live-action characters
without worrying about
a single camera move
ruining the illusion.
Wētā also used real-time
compositing on the first "Avatar,"
but the traditional combining
of CG and live-action footage
is typically done in layers.
Eric: Back in the day, you
sort of had an A over B,
which meant you had either
the live action or the CG,
and it was one over the other.
Narrator: The new system
built for "The Way of Water"
looked at each shot's elements
in pixels instead of layers.
Eric: We wanted to place
the depth of each pixel
as we were shooting,
so that instead of doing A over B,
we could take each point on space and say,
you are either in front or
behind the other character.
Narrator: And that helps
achieve the correct scale.
Eric: You could actually
see how big someone was,
because otherwise you're just
getting that fake perspective,
even inadvertently,
because a character is always
over the top of one another.
Narrator: Thanks to all
of Wētā's innovations,
making a character look bigger or smaller
is no longer a guessing game.
Those perspectives can be less forced.
But even in the completely CG Pandora,
some of the most convincing
scale illusions are tangible,
like when Quaritch holds up
his own human-sized skull.
On set there was an actual prop skull,
but scaled down from human size.
That way, the actor's
hand looked Na'vi-sized.
Eric: When he crushes it,
it feels like a normal-sized skull,
because you never think about
his hand being a small, normal-sized hand.
You just assume it's the
Na'vi's hand crushing it,
because you go from a
shot of Slang to a hand,
and your brain just fills
it in as just a big hand
instead of a painted smaller hand.